les clients entre rarement dans une
boulangerie avec des fleurs mais à
Chalezeule cette journée à différentes
des autres elle met un terme à 4 ans de
partage et de convivialité
une journée où les larmes se mêlent tout
sourire c'est très difficile pourquoi
pour les clients pour tout ce qu'on a
mis en 14 ans
pour notre famille qui est passée
là-dedans qui finir sans rien on a plus
rien on part à zéro
c'est une famille c'est voilà il y a des
enfants aussi qui sont présents donc
c'est leur enfant qui sont étaient là on
les avait un petit peu grandir aussi
donc voilà c'est c'est autre chose ça va
manquer ça va manquer la boulangerie
était aussi un lieu de partage où les
clients avaient leurs habitudes des
clients souvent des amis qui regrettent
que le courage et le travail ne soit pas
récompensé
comme je connais très bien le Manu lui
qu'il était là presque 24 sur 24
qui travaillait à sa boulangerie puis sa
femme aussi donc ça ça doit être très
très dur pour eux on est en moyenne en
4005 de moyenne
en facture EDF et là on est passé à
15000 sur le mois de novembre 2022
donc avec une consommation d'un tiers de
moi c'est totalement la justice c'est il
y a pas d'autres mots c'est même
dégueulasse
c'est impensable quoi je passe en été
pour payer des factures EDF exorbitantes
dans cette boulangerie familiale les
mesures prises par l'État pour aider les
petites entreprises sont arrivées trop
tard les clients aussi sont députés je
pense qu'il faudra faire quelque chose
parce que on peut pas avoir de boucherie
ni de boulangerie etc quoi il y a un peu
plus cher pour ces petits commerces
continuent à exister en plus du couple
de boulanger six salariés vont perdre
leurs emplois ils devraient rapidement
retrouver du travail dans un secteur en
perpétuellement de main d'oeuvre